le trou de mémoire le trou de mémoire
est une araignée de cervelle qui
ne connaît qu'une seule technique de
chasse a surpris si traditionnellement
le mois molière à lui en juin
cette année la manifestation a dû être
annulée en raison de la coved 19 pour
pallier l'impact culturel et mettre à
l'honneur les artistes
le maire de la ville a mis en place un
nouveau festival plaisirs d'été il ya eu
un vrai malaise à l'idée de se dire que
tous ces professionnels spectacle ne
pouvait plus travailler il faut être
conscient tenait main que depuis donc le
mois de mars
il ne travaille plus et je crois que
dans ces moments de grande difficulté 1
2 de tension
c'est important de maintenir une vie
culturelle
une bonne nouvelle pour le public et
versailles et qui permet de renouer avec
les artistes et le monde du spectacle
c'est ce qui m'a le plus manqué pendant
toute cette période de confinement et
des confinement et le fait qu'on ait ce
cadeau là
fin août et début septembre avec des
spectacles de plein air
c'est vraiment un très grand plaisir et
c'est très important pour moi
mois de juin d'habitude il ya du théâtre
et des des festivités que j'aime
beaucoup et là ce plaisir d'été est un
plaisir de fin d'été est un rêve pour
moi un peu plaisir
si le monde culturel a été fortement
impactée par la crise sanitaire
le virus peut devenir une force pour le
monde du théâtre c'est ce qu'expliquait
christophe barbier metteur en scène du
spectacle le tour du théâtre en 80
minutes
c'est un grand plaisir de retrouver les
spectateurs même masqué c'est pas un
problème c'est un grand plaisir de
montrer que le théâtre est plus fort que
le virus plus fort que l'épidémie ne
montrait même que le théâtre peut
participer d'une sorte de de lutte de
thérapie contre l'épidémie et toutes les
peurs qu'il ya autour
le festival plaisirs d'été a lieu
jusqu'au 6 septembre programme et
réservations sur le site festival
plaisirs d'été point fr